it takes brahim kerabne around 30
minutes to get to school every day
ibrahim is nine years old and lives with
his family in the russia teen bedouin
community in the occupied west bank
he's been at this school since it was
built two years ago earlier this month
the israeli military ordered it to be
demolished
for now 50 students go to school here
to get to the other nearest school they
have to walk over
hills we used to leave home at 6am and
arrive to school exhausted at 8.
transportation was difficult at times we
were late and missed classes
palestinians need israeli permits for
buildings roads and infrastructure but
they are almost impossible to get
israel only gave 33 building permits to
palestinians in the west bank between
the years of 2017 and 2021
the peace now organization says more
than 20 thousand permits for illegal
settlement units were granted in the
same period
many palestinians say they'll build with
or without permits
in january activists built this school
at the bedouin community of insamia they
say they finished construction before
the israeli army could prevent them
it's a simple structure five rooms
and a bathroom
yet for most palestinians education is
not just about learning maths and
languages
but rather the abcs of living under
occupation
officials tell us that perseverance is
the most important part of the
curriculum
we don't have factories or natural
resources so our investment is in our
children's education we have no other
option the rossite in school has also
made it easier for girls to continue
their education
sometimes children run into settlers and
israeli soldiers on the way to school so
parents keep them at home especially
girls we want this school to stay
because students enjoy studying here and
want to attend every day
activists and officials have built 25
schools in defiance of the israeli
restrictions last year nine demolitions
took place somewhere schools demolished
for a second time after being rebuilt
and the number of demolition orders is
rising
all these children are asking for is
their right to education
ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied west
bank